وصلت القوات الاوكرانيه عمليتها الهجوميه
في اتجاهات
وحققت نجاحا في عده اتجاهات الحقنا خسائر
كبيره في صفوف العدو على مستوى الافراد
والمعدات كما سدت قواتنا هجمات روسيه
تركزت على محوري
عملياتنا الهجوميه مستمره في اتجاه بخموت
وفي مناطق ارخوي
وحققنا نجاحات في تلك العمليات معنا من
الدروس
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود وتنضم الينا
ايضا لاحقا مراسلتنا كارمنج خضار حسان اذا
حديث اوكراني عن تحقيق تقدم في اتجاهات
برديانس
ما تفاصيل في هذا السياق
بالفعل بعدما كانت الهجمات المضاده كما
تصفها اوكرانيا قد بدات مطلع هذا الشهر
عند الجبهه الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه
لاوكرانيا تحديدا جنوبي زابولوجيا وجنوبي
دنيتك وهناك تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها
تحقق تقدما عند اكثر من محور واكثر من
جبهه اخر المحاور التي تمكنت من تحقيق
مكاسب فيها كما اعلنت كانت بلده ريف نوبل
وهي الواقعه عند الحدود بين مقاطعتين
وتؤكد القياده العسكريه هناك في هذه
المنطقه التي تسمى منطقه تافيريا ان
الهجمات متواصله وانها تواجه صعوبات في
التقدم بسبب الالغام وصعوبه الاوضاع عند
هذه الجبهه والتحصينات التي بناها الجيش
الروسي عند هذه الجبهه لكنها تواصل التقدم
باتجاه منطقتين كبيرتين اساسيتين
وهاتين المنطقتين وان كانتان ما زالتا
بعيدتين بشكل كبير عن المناطق تمركز
القوات الاوكرانيه الان ومناطق الجبهه الا
ان القوات الاوكرانيات تحاول الوصول اليها
بلده تلوى الاخرى وتقول انها تتقدم
بالامتار وان كانت هذه الجبهه هي التي
كانت قد اشتعلت منذ بدايه هذا الشهر الا
ان منطقه باخموت عاده لتشهد تطورات خلال
ايام الاخيره بشكل متسارع ومتصاعد ايضا
هذه الجبهه بعد الاحداث التي جرت مع قوات
فاجنر التي كانت بشكل اساسي هي التي تقاتل
هناك تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها تنفذ
هجمات بشكل متزامن باتجاه شمالي وجنوبي
منطقه بخموت نحن الان على هذا الطريق
الاساسي الواصل الى منطقه باغموت غرب هذه
المنطقه
وهناك نرصد كيف ان القوات الاوكر لا تقوم
بتعزيز تلك المنطقه بشكل متواصل
بالامدادات العسكريه
وبالاليات وفي ذات الوقت قبل قليل سمعنا
اطلاق
دفعه من الصواريخ من هذه المنطقه من غرب
باخموت باتجاه منطقه باخمت ايضا بشكل مكثف
وهذه الجبهه شهد تطورات تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها تقدمت بحدود كيلو مترا
واحد شمالي وجنوبي هذه المنطقه وتنشر ايضا
القوات الاوكرانيه مقاطع فيديو تظهر هذه
الهجمات التي تقوم بها والمعارك في داخل
الخنادق بين القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات
الروسيه لا سيما عند جبهه جنوبي لكن ايضا
تطورات الاخرى منطقه كراسي هذه هي من
المناطق الواقعه بالقرب من حدود
المناطق الاوكرانيه
التي كانت القوات الروسيه قد سيطرت عليها
منذ 2014 تقول قوات الاوكرانيه انها ايضا
نفذت هجمات تكتيكيه في تلك المنطقه بهذا
الاتجاه وتمكنت من استعاده بعض المواقع في
تلك المنطقه كل ذلك جرى عند في خلال
الفتره التي كانت القوات الروسيه في ازمه
داخليه بين قوات التي كانت تعمل في هذه
المنطقه وايضا القوات الروسيه ولكن الان
نرصد ونتابع تطورات هذه الجبهات بعد
انتهاء هذه الازمه نعم